you said something a moment ago find
your tribe as someone who may have felt
like an outsider and I only say this
because I've felt like one my entire
life so how do you find your tribe
because there's there's a tendency to
want a glob on tonight my name is
shuttle ward but you want to like you
know fit in with this group because you
think then that's gonna take you where
you need to go but it's not really a fit
I don't know what your tribe is you
don't you just don't just do what you
love man it's all you can do all you can
do is do what you want to do that's how
you find them who those people are gonna
be no idea but you just have to do what
you do if you do what they do
then you're chasing their tribe and
they're not necessarily necessarily your
tribe so you're just chasing after
people like you know people-pleasing
which is something I've had big problem
with in the past you can't do that it's
not it's not good for you and it's not
good for them you're really wasting
everybody's time when you're trying to
please everybody you know what I mean
I think I think you just have to do what
you do do you as the kids say right you
know well it's interesting why isn't it
good for them because I can see why it
wouldn't be good for the individual
trying to be the people please right
right eventually you'll either excuse me
let them down and they'll get mad at you
right or whatever but why why not for
them why why should I care about people
pleasing why why does it hurt the group
why does it hurt the group you're trying
to please yeah cuz I'll ventually you
can't keep that up it's a lie so you're
basically telling a bunch of people that
they can depend on you to do what they
want it's not what you want you're gonna
crack eventually and then there's gonna
be a waste of their time and your time
right so why do it who cares
you don't you just have to love what you
love
there's seven billion people on the
planet
I guarantee at least three of them love
what you love that's all you really need
you just need to find three other people
that like what you like you're good
you're fine and they're out there you
just have to do what you do and just
follow that the truer you can be to your
cell
and what you dig the better I think for
everybody because this stuff's hard it's
not easy to make movies and all of this
stuff you might as well love it because
if you're gonna do hard stuff do hard
stuff they're gonna pay you tons of
money for you know hey hey go do hard
stuff I don't know do math or something
I don't know
architecture architecture he'll be an
architect that's hard but you know
they'll pay you a lot of money up front
better I think you just have to you have
to do you have to do this cuz you love
it because it's burning in ya and then
you find the other people so let's take
an example of someone trying to be a
people pleaser as an actor or filmmaker
and then another way to not do that but
still be dependable sorry so you so's so
like if you want if you're an actor or a
filmmaker or both you want to be
dependable to people you end up working
with but you don't want to be a people
pleaser what's an example of each I
think it it's the same thing it's just
doing what you love because the thing is
if you love doing something you're gonna
do it people don't do anything they
don't want to do and they only do what
they have to do well sometimes for a
paycheck but they have to do that they
have to yeah so so you're only gonna do
what you have to do outside of that
you're done do anything you don't want
to do if you're doing something you
don't want to do it's cuz you have to do
it sure Sean you know I mean how did you
catch yourself in being a people pleaser
and how did you change it I'm still
doing it man I'm still I'm still trying
to get over it yeah you end up when you
end up in situations where you feel like
you want to work with people you feel
like you're gonna gain something out of
that situation you feel like you know
it's gonna be mutually beneficial and
sometimes it is and sometimes it isn't
and sometimes you get in there and it's
just not working you know and and you'd
have to be able to say okay well it's
not it's not working like it's you've
got you have to you have to take
ownership of your own life you have to
take ownership
what you're going to do because what
other people are gonna do that's what
they're gonna do it's got nothing to do
with you
you know it really it really it really
doesn't you can only control what you
are gonna do what you are capable of and
what you love so you might as well do
the thing you love because you know
you're gonna do it and that makes you
dependable so if you're gonna do it
because you love it you're gonna run
into the people that love the same thing
and now it's mutually beneficial because
you're dependable because you both love
the same thing but if I come to you and
I say hey yeah come on Karen we're gonna
do this thing's giving awesome and
you're like yeah we're gonna make the
best sci-fi horror thing ever and I'm
like yeah and then I go home I hate
sci-fi Ennore I was gonna say that yes
stand it but whatever Karen she knows
some people isn't awesome so we keep
doing it it's not gonna be the best that
I can do I don't really like it and
you're gonna be like um I don't think
this works and this works and this works
I mean like what the hell difference
does it make it's just sci-fi horror who
cares
you just have to kill people in space
what's the big deal and you'll be like I
love this now you tell me
now you've wasted your time their time
everybody's upset you know what I mean
so you don't do it you just do what you
you do the thing you think is awesome
not the thing you think is awesome or
the thing you think other people are
gonna find awesome do what you think is
awesome and then the people that think
that thing's awesome will show up to
everybody thought Star Wars was psycho
when they first did it get it now
you